nous sommes avant deux heures du
spectacle des moines shaolin c'est la
tête d'affiche de ce festival
mais les gens sont déjà présents depuis
le milieu de la matinée pour participer
à des stages de danse tout à l'heure
c'était le costa rica
je vous laisse découvrir le reportage
que nous avons tourné avec pierre
dominique le pet et raphaël fischer
classée parmi les pays les plus heureux
du monde
on connaissait aussi le costa rica pour
ses costumes traditionnels
on découvre en plus de cela qu'ils ont
le rythme dans la peau et ce n'est pas
pour déplaire aux festivaliers et
festivalière venu en vie
[Musique]
ça permet de connaître leur façon de
danser c'est très imposante attiches la
danse faut coordonner les mains les
pieds c'est un peu difficile mais ça
vient ça permet de voyager sans bouger
son frère est-ce que sans bouger durant
cette tournée on a vu de nombreux
groupes de français et ils sont
incroyables et ici dans ce type de
présentation cet impressionnant de voir
comment ils apprennent vite
c'est bon de danser avec plusieurs
styles de musique sont joués comme la
musique gonna castaic avec des
influences espagnoles cubaine et
colombienne toujours accompagné de
courchamp joyeux
[Musique]
un apprentissage difficile pour les
français mais qui se déroule forcément
dans la bonne humeur
[Musique]
je suis à présent avec anaïs et mehdi
vous avez tous les deux 23 et 21 ans sur
ce festival ya quand même 250 bénévoles
près de 70 jeunes anej quel est le but
de votre travail
alors le but c'est de gérer tous ces
jeunes avec les plannings faire en sorte
qu'ils aient beaucoup d'échangés
beaucoup de partage avec les groupes et
qui est surtout une bonne ambiance mais
disent que c'est une pression quand même
d'être chef bénévoles c'est une pression
avant le festival parce qu'il faut qu'on
organise tous les baning il faut qu'on
prépare les jeunes peu con mais
s'inscrivent tout une démarche à faire
avec eux c'est une pression pendant
parce qu'il a tous les préparatifs les
débriefings avec eux et après là pour
l'instant c'est plutôt cool pour nous
parce que ça roule
après ça va être aussi dangereux vous
êtes jeunes tous les deux
l'été quand on est jeune on a plutôt
envie de faire déjà pour gagner un petit
peu d'argent qu'est ce qui vous motive
dans le faire de faire du bénévolat
c'est vraiment le partage envie de
partager beaucoup de choses et de
transmettre surtout beaucoup de choses à
nos jeunes moi j'ai la chance de pouvoir
prendre des vacances pour sagesse que
c'est une passion ça fait quand même 50
je le fais c'est vrai j'aime bien ce que
je fais c'est enrichissant c'est plein
de
deux valeurs humaines qu'on retrouve
essayez donc jamais instructions
venaient est si génial